le nouveau gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron vient à peine d'être prononcé
qu'il crée déjà la polémique cette
affaire abah dès la mise en cause de
damien abad damien abad est au coeur de
la tempête damien abad nouveau mini des
solidarités fait face à des accusations
de viol révélée ce week-end par
mediapart deux femmes accusent dans sa
députée l air de violences sexuelles sur
des faits remontant à 2010 et 2011 et
forcément ce pose la question qu'ils
savaient et qui savait quoi inquiet du
côté de l'opposition certains réclament
sa démission immédiate
si c'était elle est fille on aurait dit
bah écoute on le relève de la bomba
temps damien abad a décidé de se
maintenir à son poste de ministre
dénonçant une machination un homme
innocent doit-il démissionner je ne
crois pas de son côté l'exécutif assure
n'avoir jamais été mise au courant de
tels agissements alors accusé de deux
viols le ministe damien abad doit-il
déjà être viré
alors merci merci nelly d'être avec nous
formidable directrice de l'observatoire
triste nouvelle nelly garni enlevez vos
dons parce que la photo mais telle n'est
pas l'image de ce qu'est nelly qui est
magnifique
merci d'être là je tellement content de
le voir c'est une amie un peu la donne
dans les lycées ne devait préférer dans
le monde politique et dans le monde de
la france
sammis fac ci et avec mon serment sami
salo danis de ses new skies vient nous
voir voilà dès qu'il en a l'occasion et
on adore quand il est là également et
c'est vrai que cette affaire tout le
monde en parle et c'est fou parce que
moi je me pose toujours la question ce
que l' on pose les questions que
personne ne pose sur les autres chaînes
quand le gars sait qui va être dans la
sauce pourquoi il accepte d'être
ministre il sait très bien que des qui
va nécessairement va être sûr c'est
qu'il connaît ça mais c'est vrai tu vois
chine berden et c'est très bien qu'on va
lui parler de ses notes de frais
comment le gars se dit je vais y aller
ça va passer quand même c'est vrai parce
que quand vous avez des pratiques
pendant des années et que personne ne
parle parce que en fait partout vous
avez les violences sexistes et sexuelles
c'est parfois pour ça je reprend la
métaphore de l'inceste pourquoi il ya
l'inceste dans une famille parce que
tout le monde tient l'omerta et tout le
monde tient le silence et dans des
structures où vous avez des violences
sexistes et sexuelles
et bien tout le monde tient de silence
et donc quand pendant des années vous
avez des pratiques et que vous avez vu
que tout le monde 15 silence vous avez
un sentiment d'impunité qui s'installe
et vous vous dites les gens ne vont
jamais parlé et puis vous plus vous
devenez puissant que vous vous dites
elles vont pas oser parler maintenant
donc je pense que c'est ça qui fait que
les gens ne se sentent pas en danger
alors cette affaire elle fait énormément
parler sami est ce que vous pouvez nous
faire un résumé de ce qu'on sait de
cette affaire pour les téléspectateurs
qui nous rejoignent bien sûr en fait
tous comment ce vendredi après midi
vendredi après-midi alexis colère le
secrétaire général de l'elysée il est
énervé bien sûr le
annonce la composition du greta alexis
colère au gouvernement ils ne sortent
que quand il ya un cas qui
légua ya un problème sortait lexicologue
ça me casse et les
colères saguenay dans une pièce d'ekin
un bel essor et les colères
d'adapter colère mais on est mon
meilleur je connais bien sympa le rsa et
l'apa il n'a pas peur d'eux voilà alors
donc à mexico leers les vendredis après
midi les vénère donc il annonce la
composition du gouvernement on a
programmé un bad récupère le
portefeuille du ministère des
solidarités
quelques heures après nos confrères de
mediapart révèle des accusations qui
sont extrêmement graves deux femmes deux
accusatrices qui est bien expliqué à
médiapart qu'elles ont été victimes de
viols et d'agressions sexuelles par amir
abad l'une des accusatrices à porter
deux fois plainte une fois en 2012 et
une fois en 2017 les deux plaintes ont
été classées sans suite et l'autre
accusatrice et bien alerté l
observatoire des violences sexuelles et
les agressions sexuelles cimpor
politique ensuite donc la conséquence
politique de ça le samedi elisabeth borg
premier ministre est en déplacement le
calvados elle est interrogée sur
justement ce sujet avec le ton
extrêmement ferme elle explique
justement qu'il n'y aura aucune impunité
s'il ya de nouveaux éléments et c'est là
où c'est intéressant c'est que dès le
dimanche il ya une forme de
rétropédalage de la part de l'exécutif
en expliquant que seule une décision de
justice pourra faire sortir damien abad
en tout cas pour la débrancher damien
abad du gouvernement donc autrement dit
il est sûr que elisabeth bornes et
emmanuel macron ce qu'ils étaient avant
de faire cette annonce mais c'est là où
la question se pose qu'est ce qu'une
décision de justice est ce que c'est une
mise en examen est ce que c'est un dépôt
de plainte est ce que c'est une enquête
préliminaire et c'est là où le
gouvernement est extrêmement sous sur
cette question il n'y a pas de ligne
directrice de la part d' emmanuel macron
appuyer une autre question si je peux me
permettre aussi cyril c'est que quand
vous êtes nommé ministre toute notre vie
était plus hachée que ce soit votre
passé administratif mode passif fiscal
on regarde si en gros vous avez payées
aux impôts bien sûr et votre passé
judiciaire aussi épluché patrick savez
très bien le gouvernement que il y avait
ces deux plaintes qui avait été classée
sans suite et avait parlé des villes
allemandes isabelle borne que alors on
veut pas de politique il m'assure
écrit-il mais c'est vrai que j'aime
beaucoup me disent ah ben voilà je veux
l'occasion de faire des émissions avec
elle et ils avaient deux bandes très
récemment que je connais très bien son
frère éric un petit français à ces
questions
gilbert d'ici et d'ailleurs il le savait
il le savait et il a visité il a hésité
lui même accepté le poste parce qu'il
savait que les témoignages allait
arriver être rendu public jeudi qu'il a
beaucoup hésité et il a obtenu dit on
des garanties qui seraient pas virer si
ça sortait voilà et à lisa il l'avait
dit avant oui il en fait il le savait
lui et selon mes infos il aurait dit ça
va sortir on lui aurait dit on te prend
quand même pour la sauver pour vous il
doit rester où il doit il doit sortir il
doit être viré parce que c'est pas
tenable à la licence est pas tenable ça
pollue totalement ne parle plus que de
ça pour moi même avant une décision de
justice le le président de la république
ne peut pas s'encombrer si je puis dire
nelly qu'est ce que vous entendez le
bruit des oiseaux ils doivent le sortir
moi je pense qu'il doit sortir vous
savez depuis cinq ans depuis premier
mythe où on a vécu une vague nouvelle de
libération de la parole des femmes et le
message qu'on a essayé de dire parce que
c'est très dur de parler parce que
souvent que vous êtes parlez vous êtes
vous devez changer de métier vous devez
changer de vie parce que vous êtes exclu
vous êtes ça crée beaucoup de voix là de
problèmes et donc on a dit pour que ça
fonctionne il faut dire la parole d'une
femme qui dit qu'elle est victime elle
est aussi importante que la parole d'un
homme qui dit qu'il est innocent et
qu'est ce qu'on constate depuis cinq ans
à chaque fois qu un ministre a été
accusé des femmes ont dit voilà je suis
victime de cet homme est bien on a
d'abord cru le ministre a été le cas
avec nicolas hulot ça a été le cas avec
nick avec gérald darmanin et aujourd'hui
c'est le cas avec damien abad et on
pensait qu'on allait peut-être changer
de braquet sur ce nouveau quinquennat et
moi je trouve que c'est une clarté rila
je veux donner un peu vous vraiment que
marion bla on a vu aujourd'hui c'est
dans un autre monde on a vu plus que
besson avait été relaxé la définit quand
j'envoie la banshee définitivement appel
mais voilà on appelle ce qu'il y avait
été relaxé le point fort il a été relaxé
une deuxième fois en appel donc est-ce
qu'il faut pas attendre une décision de
justice voilà c'est vous savez c'est pas
ne nommer que dans ce cas unique mais
sont ils auraient été ministre de la
culture b bat il aurait été mis dehors
dans le mille quelqu'un ministre ou ne
pas le nommer c'est pas une décision
judiciaire c'est pas le condamner ou pas
le condamner c'est lui donner beaucoup
de pouvoir c'est lui donner un poste
très important c'est le mettre dans la
lumière c'est aussi avoir un rôle
d'exemple donc vous n'êtes pas obligé de
nommer vous avez vous quand vous prenez
quelqu'un autour de votre plateau vous
prenez 6 11 ans vous dire que ça tue
c'est cyril il ya des accusations tu
sais il reste tard avec les stagiaires
il a quand même dès qu'on parle en
apprentissage
il habite justement c'est vraiment ce
qui pose question ben vous allez hésité
à le nommer mais aussi pour protéger vos
équipes vous allez vous dire peut-être
que si je lui donne beaucoup de pouvoir
lille va mal utiliser ce pouvoir mais
vous savez après moi je joue bien je
pense connaît le monde politique vous
savez très bien que depuis longtemps il
ya des défis on leur dit surtout fait
attention de pas prendre l'ascenseur
notre sol avec ce nul a surtout fait
attention ne pas rester trop tard et pas
le croiser dans le couloir c'est pas
normal on a un rôle de protection et
qu'est ce qu'on en voit comme signal
quand on donne toujours plus de pouvoir
qu'on le fait que promouvoir les gens
qui sont mis en cause moi je vais vous
dire un truc très nature courant de
cette affaire vont pas du cta et je vais
vous dire quelque chose de très
important pour moi regardez quand il ya
eu la férule aux tripes et des infos 20
femmes qui témoignent pour qu'on les
croit ppda hulot faut quasiment une
dizaine darmanin ghana est de il y en a
pas suffi à bagdad deux si elle n'a pas
suffi comment dans ce contexte vous
pouvez dire la parole d'une femme
victime elle vaut la parole d'un homme
agresseurs à chaque fois faut qu'ils
aient des dizaines de femmes pour qu'on
commence à se dire il ya un problème bah
ça je trouve que rien que ce symbole il
est extrêmement mauvais on ne parlera
pas bien sur ce sujet parce qu'on est on
est on est extrêmement pressés mais
juste jouer des noms parce que je
jugerai chaque fois voilà je veux savoir
pourquoi non vraiment est ce que vous
étiez au courant la question qui vous
est posée est ce que vous étiez au
courant vous alors moi j'étais au
courant comme tout le monde dans la
valeur tire républicain de l'article de
closer qui est sortie pendant la
campagne à ce qu'on leur dit c'est qui
faisait état d'une plainte qui avait été
déposée par une jeune fille il disait
qu'elle avait eu un rapport consenti
d'abord et qui lui avait imposé une
pratique non consentie qui était une
sodomie forcé est donc ce il n'était pas
damien abad n'était pas nommé dans cet
article de closer met tout le monde
autour de moi à l'époque dans la
campagne avait dit que c'était il
s'agissaitt damien abad on était en
pleine tourmente françois fillon donc le
sujet avait été vite évacuée et par la
suite je n'ai jamais entendu parler sauf
si c'est pour ça que j'étais décontracté
un courant depuis alors pourquoi
je l'avais vu que l'article de closer et
j'étais pas dans une position qui
m'amenait avoir d'autres types
d'informations moi c'est pour ça que
j'aime et non comme ça me l'a dit ils
épluchent la vie du gars avant de le
nommer c'est pour ça que ça a été long
en plus c'est vraiment il a été long
parce qu'il en avait touché la vie de
tout le monde quel intérêt le
gouvernement de macron à a nommé un mec
qui a déjà eu des accusations de viol
maintenant je ne dis pas qu'il n'a pas
violé ces qui sont ces arguments de dire
je ne peux pas dans ma condition c'est
pas possible c'est pas vrai moi j'y
crois pas une seconde il peut il peut le
faire même comme ça même avec son
handicap donc ça son argument j'y crois
pas maintenant moi j'aimerais jusmy non
parce que j'aimerais que ça aille très
vite très vite parce que lui plus qu'un
autre puisqu'on l'a nommé ministre c'est
qu'on mise sur lui donc faut vite le
sortir de cette histoire et s'il ya le
moindre doute sur le moindre violent
faut le sortir du gouvernement au plus
vite mais là ça fait quatre cinq jours
qui a été nommé une semaine donc je me
dis qu'il faut aller très très vite pour
pouvoir le sortir au plus vite s'ils
font de sortir donc faut faire vite on
fait faut faire très vite
un ministre mais en face on le vit comme
tout au plus vite non tout le monde
c'est pas parce qu'il est ministre il
faut attendre au plus faire au plus vite
oui bonsoir moi j'ai mis non parce que
effectivement je trouve que le problème
vient de ce qu'ils ont nommée et tu peux
pas y avoir un deux poids deux mesures
parce que darmana aussi un cas dupond
moretti est mise en examen
on peut pas
fumer ont conduit est classé
dans management
il me met y avoir un deux poids deux
mesures de dupond moretti est pas mis en
examen je me trompe l'examen d'un côté
on dit qu'on attend une décision de
justice pour lui mais de l'autre côté
pour le ministre de la justice cela se
passe rien c'est aberrant il faut que
une règle pour tout le monde qui soit
claire lisible et que et que tout soit
je vais la moralisation de la vie
publique
elle est pas vraiment en marche j'ai pas
mal de gens qui m'écrivent qui me disent
des choses j'ai lu un tweet hat a dit
jean-claude j'ai été victimes de
dénonciations calomnieuses par cinq
femmes manipulées par un syndicaliste
accusé de harcèlement sexuel et bien que
ces femmes se soit rétractée j'ai vécu
cinq ans d'en faire virer de mes
fonctions mais personne n'en parle
plainte classée sans suite
c'est ce que j'ai dit votre ami je
lisais le problème ces histoires qui
sont terribles effrayante et que
heureusement que la parole des femmes se
libère et qu'on dénonce des choses cela
dit l'histoire damien abad elle est
ancienne 1 depuis qui était porte parole
du gepci yon vendée compte mail à
l'histoire c'est que il m'a dit niveau
condamner quelqu'un comme ça déjà le
tribunal médiatique l'a déjà condamné
d'accusation et si c'est pas vrai et si
c'est pas vrai c'est vrai vous avez
tellement de femmes qui ont jamais
parler quand vous regardez surtout les
viole toutes les agressions sexuelles
quand vous faites des enquêtes de
victimation vous vous rendez compte du
nombre de femmes agressées sexuellement
qui n'ont jamais témoigné donc on peut
pas je dirais un moment il faut
comprendre que c'est aujourd'hui le il
faut être du côté des femmes faut
libérer la parole il faut croire leurs
paroles alors je comprends que ye le
risque mais ce qu'il faut pas attendre
une décision d'ici et il faut cent dix
cadavres et est la vraie question ce
soir c'est doit-on attendre une décision
de justice pour le sortir ou faut-il de
s'imposer sur nos gouvernements voilà
bah oui mais on ne peut pas se cacher
sont entièrement derrière les
10% des affaires qui ne débouchent pas
sur une condamnation parce que c'est
extrêmement compliqué comme je le disais
à la pause vous avez le cas de la faire
vous avez un rapport qui est consenti au
début et ensuite vous avez une pratique
qui n'est pas consenti vous avez une
sodomie forcé comment vous pouvez
dessiner à part parole contre parole ça
devient impossible donc c'est très très
dur par rapport par ailleurs les femmes
est souvent longtemps à parler elle
hésite à s'engager dans des procédures
longues donc on peut pas tout basé sur
la justice y ait un deuxième point c'est
ce que j'appelle la zone grise c'est que
vous pouvez avoir des témoignages qui
font que vous avez une accumulation de
comportement ou vous dites moi j'ai pas
envie que les gens il se comporte comme
ça parce que c'est des comportements
systématiquement déplacer avec les
femmes et ça va pas donner lieu
systématiquement à des condamnations je
veux dire aujourd'hui appelé la police
pour dire mon voisin me fait que des
blagues lourdes non et pourtant vous
pouvez dire non ses voisins non
[Rires]
publique
jusque alors castany qui n'a pas parlé
puis deux toilettes tout à l'heure et je
parle absolument
ça fait des années qu'on arrête pas de
pas de la libération de la parole de la
femme c'est cette fois ci on attend
encore une décision de justice c'est
impossible on passe nous on a condamné
le petit nom vous dit font pas le virer
ce n'est pas ce qui s'est passé ce qu'il
faut lui il faut attendre des signes
distinctifs déjà très directs dès leur
donner une question mais non
je veux un nom ah bah non germes terminé
tout juste les sources est donc ça fait
des années qu'on parle de ça on a compté
de légende avant même qu'ils soient qui
ce sujet arrive et on l'a condamné ppda
aujourd'hui je suis désolé il et
juriquement il est pas con a dénoncé
jour là pourquoi le mieux on va le
chercher demain à paris de luc besson
l'instant quasi relaxe et lebesson on
appelle donc il ya un point de vue
juridique impôts de vue moral si
aujourd'hui on doit accepter le plan du
moral à savoir qu on doit croire les
femmes il a plus rien à faire au
gouvernement ils devraient déjà deux
parties c'est évident c'est évident
alors céline twitter qui fait la loi
c'est la justice mme norma maintenant
mes infos qui est sorti matinée en
attendant jusqu'à 100 mio c'est vrai ce
n'est pas twitter flickr matinaux était
au courant la france à pau vient de
sortir maintenant offerts matinée a été
au courant avant mediapart de la teneur
des accusations donc je vous imaginez
que s'il nommait le ministre c'est qu'il
pense qu'il ne va pas être condamné en
revanche là malheureusement il a déjà
été condamné par le tribunal médiatique
c'est le tribunal médiatique qui fait la
loi quoi qu'il arrive qu'il soit
coupable ou innocent il y aura toujours
un doute autour de lui il se fait
lyncher sur les réseaux et je trouve ça
regrettable que ce soit twitter et
médiapart qui fasse le gouvernement
aujourd'hui oui mais les deux femmes
quand on lit leurs témoignages il ya des
similitudes quand même qu'ils sont assez
prenante c'est à dire que aussi on doit
prendre en considération le discours on
se fait des victimes et puis pour des
postes si important des traîtres au
gouvernement c'est pas être acteur c'est
pas être militaire c'est pas
d'humoristes on a
fait sa campagne il a expliqué qu'il
voulait faire de ce quinquennat la
grande cause justement là les violences
est la lutte contre les violences faites
aux femmes et à l'égalité homme femme ça
va être la grande cause du quinquennat
est-ce qu' il pouvait s que c'était
judicieux de prendre le risque compte
tenu de la scène médiatique et compte
tenu et c'est une très bonne chose de la
libération de la parole des femmes
est-ce que c'était judicieux de prendre
le risque d'exposer damien abad qui a eu
quand même deux plaintes même si elle
était classée sans suite justement de
faire face à cette scène médiatique je
pense que c'était pas indispensable
j'avais d'autres ministres qui aurait pu
endosser parfaitement ce rôle de
ministre des solidarités nelly gagnez
vous nous avez dit que voilà on a vu
l'article de closer en 2017 tu crois
c'est ça c'est vrai que maurice ils ont
épluché tous les dossiers ils ont dû
voir lastic de closer aussi est-ce que
s'ils ont vu tout ça et qu'ils ont comme
nommé ça veut pas dire qu'ils ont quand
même des des preuves que c'est c'est ça
va passer parce que je me dirai ça
serait complètement points je me sens
même un franchissement commençait sa
serais fou de dire on va le nommer quand
même ici on est plus hachée quand même
annoncé les leurs les choisir et vous
savez qu'un de ses collègues des
républicains aujourd'hui anonymement
évidemment vient de balancer que
justement tout le monde le savait dans
le parti des républicains et que c'était
le lourdaud ben service qu'il fallait
pas prendre l'ascenseur avec lui
toujours le même
mais moi je
ne considère pas lorient sujet
suffisamment important pour être
exemplaire soit ya une part de cynisme
et qui sont dit que le gain de faire
cette prise de guerre et l'air avait
plus de d'importance que d'écouter et
d'accueillir la parole de femme qui se
disait victime est ce qu a été le
précédent quinquennat laisse penser que
le gain politique où les intérêts
politiques de maintenir tel ou tel homme
parce que c'est un poids lourd du
gouvernement pèse plus que d'envoyer des
symboles très fort sur la question de la
lutte contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles en amont ciel mais mon siège
qui aliène t
elle le gouvernement est aux côtés alors
je lis parce que le gouvernement est aux
côtés de celles qui suite à une
agression ou du harcèlement ont
l'immense courage de parler voilà
c'était la dernière déclaration de
matignon
est-ce qu'il faut la scatologie qu'il
faut le sortir pour moi faut attendre le
jugement parce qu'on n'est pas en mesure
ne sera plus ministre déjà si on aura eu
un remaniement
bettina faire dédicacer on voit par
exemple avec la sphère de johnny depp
que c'est compliqué il ya beaucoup
d'éléments il faut prendre en compte
quand même les preuves et les
témoignages non mais c'est quand même
important attendons alors ça me dois
pour toi il faut faire quoi non mais je
veux dire je pense que ministre c'est
pas un job comme les autres après il
faut aussi répété qu'à la présomption
d'innocence qui doit s'appliquer à
chaque fois qu'on évoque en fait ce cas
mais j'en veux dire c'est un dossier
très complexe il faut pas non plus
tomber dans une forme de tribunal
médiatique et je pense très sérieusement
pour couvrir l'elysée depuis maintenant
quelques années que du côté de la
présidence il ya cette volonté de dire
en gros c'est pas comme tu disais très
bien twitter qui va justement décidé de
mon gouvernement à ces médias deux
plaintes qui s'en suit il ya eu une
accusatrice qui a justement fait qu'ils
ont faits qui a fait un signalement elle
n'a pas encore déposé plainte et je
pense que du côté des manuels macro il
ya cette volonté de rester dans une
forme d'état dorkel mais signale c'est
pas cohérent non plus avec sa volonté de
faire la lutte contre les violences ont
compensé les spectateurs merci on va
voir ce que oui oui à 60 ans sans nom à
25 ans je crois que c'est clair
on